drapeau élèves personnalités politiques
le lycée international de saint germain
en laye a vécu ce mardi 29 mars une
inauguration en grande pompe un
événement organisé après trois ans de
travaux dans cet établissement installé
dans la commune depuis 1952 et qui avait
besoin d'un lifting la cour de
récréation était à tout sauf une cour
est en tout cas pas récréative la
cantine était dans un état déplorable
les salles de cours était d'une
tristesse infinie bref c'était un outil
qui ne vivaient que par la qualité de
l'enseignement donné et certainement pas
par le cadre qu en offrant aux élèves
pour permettre aux 2300 élèves répartis
dans quatorze sections internationales
d'étudier dans les meilleures conditions
67 millions d'euros dont 28,7 millions
du département des yvelines ont été
débloqués le résultat semble satisfaire
la proviseure c'est très moderne c'est
très beau
si dubois cdu verts et il ya un
équipement numérique qui est qui est
vraiment tout à fait performant avec
100% de réussite au bac et 98 % de
mentions le lis internationaux de
saint-jean mansle et fait partie des
meilleurs établissements france cette
rénovation devrait permettre à la
structure de continuer dans cette voie
il est évident que le sujet du bâti
scolaire ce n'est pas seulement un sujet
immobilier c'est un sujet pédagogique
c'est un sujet de projets pédagogiques
c'est particulièrement important pour
les apprentissages lorsqu'on est bien
dans son corps dans l'espace et bien
on apprend bien et on apprend mieux au
total 25 mille mètres carrés de
planchers ont été ajoutés sur le site
avec cette rénovation les élèves
espèrent maintenant être à la hauteur de
ces structures qui fête cette année ses
70 ans
[Musique]